and author of a best-selling biography
of Hitler and a Pulitzer prize-winning
narrative on the Japanese Empire during
world war two died January fourth at the
age of 91 he was a guest on book notes
in 1997 to discuss his memoir captured
by history it's an hour John Tolin
author have captured by history near the
end of your book you say when I became a
communist I chose to join the American
peace mobilization i picketed for peace
in front of the White House and yet like
so many of my comrades in a PM I tried
to unless the day after Pearl Harbor
later I opposed the Korean War and
publicly decried the Vietnam and Gulf
Wars explained all that well I had
learned in my life that the worst thing
we had to face was war that nobody won
and I have come to believe that this was
the worst century of mankind because of
the award the wars that solved no
problems only developed new ones and if
this continues and we have another war i
think it's the end of the world because
we have got now I guess for example that
can wipe out other countries in a few
days I don't want that guess and I have
an idea has already been sold to several
countries go back to your statement
about being a communist when were your
comments see I was I think that was
about I was out of Williams about Forry
for you or something like that and I've
been traveling I spent four summers
writing freight trains and so forth and
finding America at her best I just loved
writing freight trains and meeting all
these wonderful people on the trains
there were no fights there I'd heard
about how the fights ahead in the
jungles which were not called jungles by
them everybody was helping everybody
else and these most of them are young
men that have left their farms because
they wanted their sisters and mothers to
have just enough money to eat and they
were out and I was following them we
were working at a week or so on picking
someone
up into another crop and I followed them
around and i'll tell you if you've ever
tried to pick lettuce believe me that's
a tough Jeff and but I found out they
helped each other there were no
animosity among them the only people
that they hated were the yard bulls that
were in the yards now on the freight
trains the head of the freight train was
called a conductor by the way and he had
about five or six men they were friends
to these riders they let them ride now
there's certain they have to lock up
certain cars sometimes you have to ride
on top various places but they were not
brutal like the d'art bulls when she got
off to start hitting it with clubs but
you'd graduate from williams college as
i was still it wasn't for me i was when
i was writing riding the rails yeah but
what was it about the communist party at
that time what was it like the
communists well when I got into the
communist party most of my friends in
New York were Jewish and we were
primarily against war and we thought the
the Communists wanted really peace we
were taken in and for example like most
people don't realize is we had to stand
in front of an American flag when we
were made come is and recite the oath to
the United States we were Americans and
that was it and then we found out this
was a fake that we had been taken in but
at this time we fought for peace and
that's why I I was chosen as one of the
two people to go down to Washington to
pick at the White House which we had a
marvelous time by the way and would you
like me to go on to what that meeting
was like sure well I was known for my
ability to work with anyone so I
traveled with blacks and we got down
there I roomed in the same hotels as
about 30 blacks were and on the second
and what we're doing we just by marching
peaceably up and
occasionally chanting a bit about peace
and so forth but nothing rowdy and but
on the second day we were kicked out of
our hotel because there were blacks and
we just didn't know what to do and we
were there unfortunately our leader was
from Hollywood and we had no faith in
him and he was pompous Singh around and
all of a sudden I saw you know her Blair
houses right next to Blair House is an
identical house came this woman stately
woman marching right up the Avenue
ignoring the traffic as if she owned the
whole place came over to us and said I
understand there are certain of you
people that were not allowed in your
hotels is that right and that's I told
her fears there about 30 of us and she
said are there people Negroes too I said
yes most of us are Negroes she said
would you like to stay in my house for
the next two days I can only give you
blankets to sleep on and so forth and
have we we will have very slight stuff
to eat and I said we would accept
graciously with it and then she turned
around I've never seen a more noble
woman and this is a one-off I seen her I
would say she was a reactionary so forth
and so on here she was offering her home
to 30 blacks and one boy who was it you
what who was the woman I don't know and
you stayed there ice we stay different
for the next to two night and she came
down to see us and we were sleeping on
floors and things like that but she was
only there to greet us and not to
inspect us you left the Communist Party
what year oh I left within two years i
left economy as party because I saw I've
been had is that has that followed you
through your life in any way does it
ever pop up word gives you trouble it
would have do you remember a character
called The Ugly American yeah this this
man of a mere can I forget what his real
name was I had first met him when I was
researching in the Philippines
and its usual I was set up at clark
field and so forth and a barrack there
and then the commanding officer there
was quite upset because i had met some
local people and getting great material
from them and i was told that we were to
be writing about Americans in this world
I said sir I'm writing a book about the
war and they cut off my transportation
I'd take a bus to the capital and the
capital that usually treated me nicely
to kick me right off out and I was
standing there wondering what to do nice
and that man came up it turned to be The
Ugly American and he said are you the
one that they want to give any
transportation I said yes he said would
you like to meet the president of the
philippines tomorrow I said I sure would
he brought me to the this big hall where
the president was it's talking to the
four military forces afterwards he
introduced me to the present who asks
what are you here for and I said I've
come to to find out what really happened
in the Philippines and he said I
understand you have trouble and he
pointed to this major very who would go
into West Point and said this man will
be your guide this man found two people
to take me I was taken to all the
islands I saw everything I wanted to for
example when I was in the island that
the second president of the Philippines
was I had been there 15 minutes and I
got a call to go up and see him and he
is that he has a Chinese name i forget
what his name was but he said he hurt i
was there and he want me to reveal
something that he had been holding back
all these years that he had been second
in command when the the president of the
Philippines went to America and he was
put in charge and he was ordered by the
President to pretend with four other of
the top people in the country to work
with the Japanese and this would be to
save the
public from a lots of problems and so
forth but he said he was he knew he was
going to die within a year and he wanted
the truth told so that these people who
had never talked would not be regarded
as they had been regarded as traitors to
their country and I said I promised I
wouldn't publish this until after his
death he said that and as I was going
out the door about a half a dozen
reporters were there and I they see a
purring away and I said what's the
matter is it Oh haven't you heard these
some dozen American senators and
congressmen arrived in the capital
yesterday and they were telling
everybody what was wrong with the with
the with with the country and so forth
and so on I said what do you think of
that and I said well he might away today
and i left at i didn't return to a clark
field until two days I had something as
I walked in the office everybody stared
at me coldly except I had one friend
this girl and I went up to he sees his
John why did you do that and I said do
what is what you told Communist Party in
like she showed me the communist
newspaper and headlines American
American senators something something
cause of riots or something and I said I
didn't say that that at all and he said
do you realize that you're now being
sent back to America the commanding
officer there he's coming up he's going
to tell you you have no yeah yeah yeah
you won't build I wouldn't be able to
ride my boat just a as in a movie who
should walk in but the commanding
general of all the air force in the in
that area of the world and for people
and I had interviewed him and Hawaii
before and he'd give me a couple of
great stories and he looked he saw me he
says hi John what are you how are they
treating you over here and he said would
you like to work
on to the next town a Hong Kong were on
leave would you like to go with us and I
said I sure would when I got into the
plane I told him the real story and all
he did was laugh and he said may I give
you some advice job whenever you asked a
question by a newspaper man say no
comment but I was always pulled out of
these things at the last minute I could
my career as a writer probably would
have ended if he hadn't walked through
the door how many books have you written
in your life that have been published
I've 14 two of them two of them were or
novels the rest were histories and what
year in your life did you start writing
12 I started writing when I was 12 and
say my father was I thought everybody
was either painter or writer my mother
was a painter my father was a singer and
I was brought up like that and but when
I was 12 years old see my father was a
big Irishman and he looked at my hands
and he says my god you have the hands of
a girl and I I said well who made me and
he didn't like that but he loved me but
I he saw me as a product of the Scotch
part of the family my mother's part now
the Scotch part they were crazy about me
my mother had three sisters none of them
had children and of course i was there
idle and then their father the
grandfather he's the one that really
changed my life and he told me one thing
he says he says John I don't you may
hear a lot of things about religion but
there's only one thing I want you to do
and I said what is that you always do
the right thing and it says but data how
will I know what it's the right thing he
says usually it's what you don't want to
do but you'll find out and this has
become my religion and it still is it's
it's a very simple thing and it has led
me through life and they say I've had a
wonderful life and some people notice it
I was a failure until I was 45 years old
and I sold my first story I had written
25 plays none of them ever put on but
those plays became the reason I wrote a
different kind of history because my
great hero was Shakespeare and he said
unto thy self be true no this seemed
very simple to me and if you'll notice
Shakespeare had no point of view when he
was writing his stories and as this
Porter Anderson Brown the great frog I
told me he said and the Greeks also and
so I was I brought into history
non-ideological history which means no
point of view and that's why a number of
people are very unhappy with me because
I treat all people the same I don't care
whether they're colored I don't care
whether the Irish or Chinese so I want
to hear all sides and just where do you
live today I think our where do you live
today I live in Danbury Connecticut are
you married is my second wife my first
wife I divorce after 10 years and I you
want to notice her pictures I had
beautiful dress she's a dancer believe
me dancers live by their feet your first
wife was in a way but I have to two
wonderful children from her two
daughters and my second wife and I have
a daughter and I have three mr. first
one my first wife as I say she's
beautiful woman and so forth but i will
say nothing about her bad in the book I
only tell how she was the one that when
i brought a black officer into the
officer's club at kezar field when I was
a second lieutenant I was kicked out of
my job I was threatened I was beaten up
and I almost killed she stuck by me and
so I just say I will only say good
things about her and then your second my
second life at touch ago we married in
nineteen sixty i went to japan i was
doing a book of my first book on the
hating old Japanese in one day I found
out I was beginning to like the Japanese
on the third day there I met toshio I
need an interpreter and when I saw her I
knew I was going to marry her but first
I had to tell her it was a rough life
you know that we live and that I was on
the road about eight months of the year
and then on I think I've been there she
became my interpreter in her in the
evenings and on the ninth day I knew her
I said would you marry me and she
instantly said yes and her father who
was a very noted a man in the he spoke
English was an Oxford accent and he was
a he was a top summer I type and he has
been trying to marry her for 11 years
and she's turning down everybody and the
he and his wife are horrified to learn
she was married an American writer and
writers the lowest form of life in Japan
and they couldn't see me for a long time
finally two days before our marriage he
they finally agreed to see me and he was
asking me he spoke this marvelous when
he was he to ride the big man for a
Japanese and he says on you've got a
divorce and we went through all that and
after about five questions the wife who
was very small she looked like a little
Buddha and she said John you will make
touch you go very happy and then we
breathed a sigh of relief I gave him a
dozen American golf balls which are
bigger than the others and he became
like greatest assistant I could not have
written the Rising Sun without him he
got me to the markets kido who was the
Emperor's chief advisor he knew
everybody in Japan and they're people
that refuse to talk to me before to talk
to any American came right in I was I
had I was allowed I even had arranged a
meeting with the Emperor himself and
then at that point you may have
that an Englishman wrote a book about
the Emperor just beating up the hill he
had come over for a week and then
described it and so I was the code that
the embassy called me and said I'm sorry
you cannot meet the his majesty and they
said what can we do anything else to
help you and I said yes you can I will
forget this if you will allow me to
interview the sixth gentleman that
served the Emperor these were people of
high class worked around I got more
about the Emperor from the six men or
what these wonderful stories personal
stories of his quirks and queries I've
got about three pages of it in the end
the Rising Sun so I had always found out
never go down defeated there sometimes
you must retreat but try to make a deal
for you can get something out of it
which one of your 12 non-fiction books
sold the most oh the autofilter that
became a big this is still a bit so
guess who just bought it now now the
Chinese just bought it now it's been
published in 25 countries and this was a
book that was turned down by my
publishers of the of the Rising Sun who
didn't particularly like the book this
is 1976 Adolf Hitler yeah and that's
that's still a big best seller has made
a fortune and my the publishers of the
Rising Sun did not like it because i was
making heroes they said of the japanese
and they had complained they published
my book to last hundred days which was a
quite a good bestseller and i had
retreated a little because they objected
to the way I made some Germans heroes
and so forth but when I wrote the Rising
Sun I saw that I had the truth because
my my wife and her whole family had
brought me in now I I felt I know that
this the whole truth and that I could
not change a single thing I had to go to
New York something like 90 times and
they kept yapping at me and I refuse
well I went off now starting research on
an auto fit and passed them the contract
on you know they turned it down they
said you have taken too much time of the
editors therefore you must go down from
twelve percent on the book to eight
percent I'm half Irish you know I told
them don't you so enough or is the best
seller yeah in time since 76 how many
copies is it salt million a million cars
more than I don't know how many copies
all I know is that it's made two million
dollars they lost to me for you I mean
that to me it came to you yeah I thought
I made that the first year i made a
million and kept filled I don't know all
of like I don't think about money I
can't figure what it is all I know is it
made a hell of a lot of money well let
me ask you this have you ever total of
the of all the books you saw how many
books you so oh god you know once i
finish the book I know I'm not like most
authors when the first book I finished I
many went to the library of congress and
i turned over all my material my
interviews and so forth and all the
things i had found out because i wanted
this to be open for other people no this
doesn't seem to make sense to some
people now then when my books got better
that that they said they couldn't handle
all the people that were coming in and
i've been working with the National
Archives they had always believed in me
and the people down there were marvelous
to me and they heard about the fact that
giving books away and they said we'd
like you to send all your material now
to the FDR why
presidential library and I said the
Presidential Library I thought he was a
bomb you know that has nothing to do
with it he said you know we've run those
ourselves I didn't know that the
National Archives they see if they send
down the people who run it and it's just
known as that library since then I have
sent all my tapes of everyone I've ever
finish a book and at there was a time
when I was offered money and so my
family said why don't you take it I said
how can I take it I didn't think it was
see I had been helped by so many people
and I think but I think good writers
want other people to follow them because
I no matter how good my books are I
think new information you should come up
we want to keep this thing going is all
of your are all of your tapes at the FDR
library not all I gave all of them that
if I also they made copies of all of
them and sent them to the library of
congress because showing my people still
thought I was so I want the Library of
Congress's and now they're told there
are certain people i say that you cannot
use these and I promise they cannot be
is until the man is dead say but outside
of that they're open to everybody and I
don't care what nationality did you say
you think that FDR was a bum I think he
was worse than that really yes why Oh
well one I got to know his wife she's a
wonderful person and you know she saved
my life and I admire her greatly now her
own family treated or miserably but he
treated her he had with three messages
at a time and things like this and I
heard stories from around that see at
first he was my great hero I thought he
was a great hero you first saw him win
when I was in college we used to come
down through from williamstown down
through the his town you know
williamstown massachusetts yeah and so
we used to come down that road which
goes right through his time and of
course I had seen him when he first ran
for president and I was and I was in a
freshman at at Williams College and he
was driving through with the president
of New York with the governor governor
of New York and the governor of
Massachusetts they were both Williams
man and they stopped there to talk and
the wyndham students around there were
95% wealthy you know and they were
booing the president you know and and
well anyway I was called I was naturally
not in any fraternity I was at the
commons club were already I had changed
their whole way of carrying trade I've
gone to extra who we had to carry two we
had two tables of eight here we had only
one table it and they were carrying a
trace while you were waiter I was a
waiter see I was offered the when I went
to Exeter I graduated and I was offered
because of my grades i was offered free
at four years free at Yale Harvard
Dartmouth and so forth and our present
the Exeter that called me and he never
spoken to me in my two years there see
after graduating from norwalk high
school I realized that I could never
make it at college unless I went to a
place like Phillips Exeter Academy
how to really study and so I love my two
years there and when I graduated as a
head offers from four of these places
and the our president called men and
this is tones he said I hear you have
all these offer I'd like you to make one
for my college it's a little college
called williams college and I said
you're going to love it because it's a
rich men's college and you'll be the
poorest boy that ever went there he said
I don't know how you did it but I know
you made more money here at extra did
anyone ever made I was had three jobs
and I was selling things I I know how to
make money and so I said fine I accept
and I went there and he and also heated
they also have a wonderful system better
than they have at Harvard I know you
want to be a writer do you know that
when you become a junior if you're
getting very high marks you can have
what we call honors work you can work
with any professor you want in a school
yourself you're the only one in the
class now if you really get high grades
you have double honors work so i know i
went there i know i had to make money to
be because after i was going to witness
the college I had heard that this famous
George Pierce Baker remember he started
Harvard and he trained some of the best
playwrights in the country and then he
had been lured down to open up the Yale
Drama School and he was running this
thing if it's a three year course and
they wouldn't have any and I could I
have to pay it would cost me something
like $20,000 so I had to not only make
all my stuff but I had to make twenty
thousand dollars in the meantime so I
could go there and he said knowing you
you're going to make it and I accepted
on the spot it was true to say when I
first went down there they sent me over
to the day I had a job working with the
commons club and I couldn't stand seeing
people riding through and when they'd go
out in the kitchen that
to bump past their way through the door
and me and I said why don't you to learn
how and I that's where I got my nickname
of shifty like it shift around and
unfortunately I was ahead man among the
fraternities because they they heard all
these stories about me and so forth and
so on not only that but see there about
20 I had have about 20 extra waiters
which worked in the fraternities during
the seasons and what happened is that at
this they suddenly cut the fees in half
and these 20 men came to me so what do
we do and I said we strike and I told us
cut it out well we beat them to it in
the head and then they came they came I
say but you must all stick together and
they all agreed to stick together and
then so the fraternities at all right
you can have the same and I said no we
want half more say well I made it there
fraternities fake and they never forgave
me for us let me go back to FDR you said
that FDR was a bomb baby I link as bombs
not the word unsavory unsavory well let
me ask you about the book infamy in for
me is when did you write em for me and
why did why did you get such criticism
well in the first place I made a
terrible mistake when I wrote the the
Rising Sun I stated from all the
everybody said Roosevelt did not know
that the Japanese task force was coming
you know and within real harm at Pearl
Harbor well within a year I've been to
get letters from top people in the US
Navy say that's nonsense we knew well I
went on for about 10 years with us and
getting more and more and like the
relatives of those you know those those
people had a navy that their lives were
ruined by all this I forget the names of
but that whole family Solomon's live so
long boys no no not them it was this
other a higher class family and the
whole family has been ruined by this and
they became my best friends and this so
let's say I told TOI shko it was very
smart I said I've got to write this
because I've made a terrible and she
said John if you do it's the biggest
mistake you've ever made they're going
to kill you later and she was right they
did I found out the facts not only from
these people in the US Navy but for
example in the Dutch the Dutchman well I
had heard a Dutchman was conceived know
he was even not an admiral at a time but
he went on to be an animal AVP became an
admiral finally that I heard about him
but nobody knew who he was and i
advertised around then i got a letter it
was from the Admiral he was living in
Texas at the time I was down there the
next day retired into her he was retired
he had me at his hotel and a he was not
he had be helped around he was if not he
was not senile he was just had hard time
getting around and his son was always
with us also I had him taped I was
called a liar I was for example this
this guy that got killed an airplane
crash recently did his main theme in
life was to try to ruin me and he
claimed that I lied about all these
things and so forth and so I just don't
understand these people that come up
with these things trying to ruin you but
you said though in an M famiy that FDR
knew about oh yes absolutely events and
I then I told my wife I had to I had to
get del Venice I def not only into these
top families the naval families that new
all is but I got this his Dutchman told
me the inside story he was the one that
secretly brought the bow
anti-aircraft gun to the US Navy's he he
was an I don't know what to call it they
don't fight that there's they just work
in various cities they're not fighters
as much as planners and he was the
planner done in Washington and therefore
planners for the Dutch yeah and see he
had a head friend in in the American
Navy and he heard that we needed the
Bofors gun say so they came to him and
he secretly he got the he knew where
were the plates and everything that you
could design the gun for he got it
through his own plane and of course it's
raised hell with this is the reason that
we were not defeated their towards at
you know and the great battle out there
and this man told me the inside story
and I got F they knew all about the fact
that the Roosevelt knew that the
Japanese what why would a Dutch military
man know the inside story because he was
working with he was the one that brought
that to the US Navy Sea and so he was
they regard him as their best man we we
later made him an honorary citizen
Admiral whatever it is they give this he
later you got the highest award you can
give to a foreigner back to go back to
the one of the themes in your book are
there every time you'd write a new book
The Book of the Month Club would pick
the book but then the judges would
overrule them well how often did that
happen and why did they overrule them
how'd that work well the this happened I
think five times they didn't like me
personally why because I was writing
things that they didn't write you know
I'm very outspoken and I say exactly
what I think and so forth and I'd say
yeah I have facts
behind me do and this irritates them but
for some reason they dislike me I could
not understand this but I was turned a
turn down five times by them but how did
that work that the who had selected and
then who would turn you down well see
they would select so many people and
then they would vote on it but that's
why i never got Book of the Month Club I
was always want but as soon as they
dumped me some other book club would
pick it up you know so but if you sold a
million copies of the Adolf Hitler book
now were there any other books that sold
Lots like that well and I know the last
hundred days sold a lot of books how
many gee I don't know I writers a
thousands or you know is this all made
you a wealthy man yeah but you see what
people didn't realize like I made a lot
of money on the last hundred days but
then my next book was going to be on on
they do a judge to the Japanese and I
needed money and so I spent all the
money I made on that to see I don't work
like other people I spend but two years
researching going all over the world and
you know it costs money to go around the
world and then the last hundred day they
the the book on Japan you know Oh yummy
no you know I have a pricing son the
Rising Sun yeah the Rising Sun one all
prizes and but I spent all the money I
made on the Rising Sun do this I had
this terrific idea about Hitler I said I
had by this time got to know all the
intimate groups within Germany that
would talk to me but it it costs a lot
of money I put all I had also saved a
hundred thousand dollars and
many my friends in Washington had been
making money through a man that was
investing for them and they said please
put your money there I put a hundred
thousand dollars in three months later I
got a report you know how about to my
hundred thousand dollars of us zero so I
had some very wealthy friends in the
town and they sent me to their lawyers
who had these lawyers only work with the
richest people in the world and you know
this famous place refused to take a cent
for me for the next five years handling
me and I was getting help and they
finally are this this this young man got
this loan for me which he never wanted
repaid which I did but he they finally
got enough money so I could start and go
back into work and I threw all that
money into this is my big book on Hitler
and by the time I finish it you see I
didn't have any money but when Hitler
came out it came out with a bang and
within a month you know I had everything
back and from then on I had so they say
I made a lot of money on these other
books but I would throw it all in on the
next book to come say but at the same
time you see I was also helping I've
children i was helping them build their
house and so forth and so on so when it
came down to how much i had was zero
let's recap though born in la crosse
wisconsin live now in Danbury
Connecticut went to Exeter Exodus
where's that located and Exeter New
Hampshire williams college graduate in
1932 spent time in the army for how long
i was a three and a half years during
the war and that
time I had I would Ridge me I wanted to
be a glider pilot because I was too old
to be a pilot so I went down there and I
was accepted by the gliders and I was in
Texas for about five months and then all
of a sudden came the report that the
first report of what happened in Asia
something like ninety percent of them
sent over were killed there's no place
to land there and so there were about 30
was there Emily all said we're not
taking any more glider pilots so I said
the hell with it and I went to Fargo
South at North Dakota and to become an
officer and I became an officer there
but she didn't serve overseas during the
military no and this I want I feel
guilty than that has never been over
there and that's one reason I read my
books Dorothy your first wife you
married in what year that was must have
been 1943 i believe i believe was 43 yes
and you had two daughters two daughters
they still alive they're still alive and
they the oldest daughter has has a son
and a daughter and the youngest daughter
has has a daughter and you married toast
go in 1960 1969 teen 68 yes way her name
is tena koe and where does she live she
was in New York and I'd like to explain
it Tamiko and japanese means a daughter
of god and she is a very self-made
person and she she know that i love
russian literature and i have many
friends in russia and so forth and you
know she kept she went to a school she
learned Russian she got to speak it
fluently she when she went to a
university majored in it Cornell she
spent a whole semester in
in Russia and so forth and so on and
then my friends and Russia when she was
out she was going to go there they told
me please get her out because they were
having problems there so she never did
work in their butt and she's now in oh
and what the deal was as but they they
make this stuff in around New York State
you know I can't think of what it was
they make well let me go anyway she's in
this business in this business now which
rather her her mother was shocked to
hear she is working in this kind of work
but what I did I went up to meet her
boss and so forth and I found out she
was doing well and sofa but I warned her
I said he's the cheapskate and he still
is but she's on her own now and doing
very well I think you won your Pulitzer
when you were 59 years old I guess so
and you're now how old I'm 85 with will
you write another book no why not I have
nothing more to say I think this book
you see I i I'm I'm working with a dozen
younger writers that they're uh I was
helped by older writers but what most
people don't realize is that in our
business if you're really good you want
somebody following you and I have many
famous people reading my plays and so
forth and trying to get made I almost
sold to my place but that didn't work
but I realized right in the 25 plays I'd
written I don't learn something about
the play has a beginning a middle and
end and this is something in history
doesn't have I brought to history my
knowledge of what should be life and
also that you should have no point of
view Shakespeare told me that he said
unto and to thy self be true and so I
actually
lieved what Shakespeare told me and then
when I was only but 12 years old this
drunken playwright came to live with us
and he taught me playwriting and he'd
been a famous playwright and he'd
written his most famous flavor was
called a bad man portr Emerson brother
dear Miss Ann Braun who you say is kind
of your mentor he really he was my hero
and see he he was a little guy and he
just adored my father was a big handsome
man with and when his wife died he took
the liquor and my father saw him drunk
downtown brought him home he says I
going to dry them out it took almost
three years but he did and during that
time Porter became my best friend and I
heard all about this wonderful play his
most famous play was called a bad man in
which this was about Pancho via but he
is he told me he said the bad man
actually in the play turns out to be a
good man he said if that were straight
it never would been successful as a
comedy this was the biggest hit on
Broadway in three years and then I said
well why did you write about Pancho
Villa he says I rode with him for three
years he said maybe you say he was a
cruel terrible person he says maybe he
was a terrible American but he certainly
was a good mexican and he said i rode
with him and he was an honorable man and
he said that's why the play was good one
of the things i noticed in your book is
that you often write how that washington
post was oh the haven I thought that
they gave you a las a review have you
seen every year they gave yesterday I
understand the usual this you know that
guy's been after me for years the guy
that wrote it and I have to get his name
areas the guy that's also written a book
on Hitler his name is clay Blair clay
polarity the second second volume of
Hitler's u-boat war will be published
next spring here's what he said about
your your book he said tollens
autobiography is a candid but pedestrian
recounting of his long struggle to reach
the top odd-job by odd-job wife my wife
age
by agent publisher by publisher editor
by editor book by book including several
failures it teems with lunches trips
dates interviews and summaries of his
books Tolan and his editors
collaborators produce some fine and some
not so fine popular military history but
regrettably he is apparently unable to
summon up the drama of his own life I
expected it why because they hate my
guess why well you see I used to review
for the Washington Post and when my book
infamy came out the two girls that ran
it called me up and said John they've
taken your book away from us is being
reviewed by the editorial department now
since when does the editorial department
and they gave it a terrible review of
course said it was the end of my of my
life as well and you couldn't have
written a rotten or one but it I
expected it from them and did you read
The Washington Times of you I'm seen it
when was it tastes terrific of course
but why would they in your opinion why
would they give you a terrific review
over the wash because they liked it I
review for them too by the way but see I
don't take the Washington Post seriously
I know that say something like that or
were so I thought I'd be worse than that
where do you end up to date politically
politically I work up with myself you
know I'm supposedly a a Republican but
I've voice both I the last times I've
ever voted Democratic because there's a
little better how long goes at I don't
know maybe four years oh but and you see
I've worked so long in Washington that
I've realized this is one of the worst
cities in the United States so much
crookedness going on there and I've
tried to reveal some of this thing they
won't publish for example I wrote a
whole series
the fact of we run our government on a
false basis which is called the writer
basis you know the writer is you go to
somebody and say book I will vote for
this bill if you will do something this
that's a writer now some of these things
have 10 pages of writers on it has
nothing to do with the poor thing you're
trying to bring into organization how
that's a hell of a way to run a run a
country and I there are some honest
people down there yes but they're having
a tough time and look at our presidents
know the one president I select was a
Truman and when I first met ought to
meet him we started by hating each
other's guts because I just discovered
from the US Navy and other people that
there was no need to drop the atomic
bomb if the so-called fear of this huge
amount of this the the greatest fighting
force had been in China and they were
supposed to go to back to Japan and and
raise hell for us the US Navy informed
me this is not true we sank them they
they all were sentient not there they
had been sent to the Philippines and we
cite three quarters of their shifts I
got this from the US Navy and so I just
let things out like that and then it
starts and eventually the truth comes
out that there was no need to drop that
bomb you're one of your techniques you
write about in here is that every time
you interviewed someone and you were
going to quote them you allowed them to
see the cohorts in advance yes and
correct it they can delete it it correct
it and you never worried about them
taking a story out that you wanted to
tell just because they didn't like the
way it came out no I don't care if they
didn't look I gave my word and I never
broke it and you see when I went over to
this side in Germany and I started
meeting people who knew Hitler and I
found a new Hitler and so forth now
found out
all these thing I've for example I found
Ava Browns best friends and I friend of
mine written a book about this woman i
forget what her name was and tonight her
nightie desk and I heard that Schneider
yeah hurt that's exactly how do you know
that I ready boo oh yeah unfortunately I
forgot not but what happened was so I
wrote an Eider and she'd being polite
says you should hope to see me but she
was planning tell me to go to hell no I
got into my German car and I saw her it
was a early winter cold as hell and the
windshield is starting to snow and rain
at the same time and the windshield
wiper stopped I had this is a trip that
would take about 45 minutes it took me
three hours I had to get out of the car
about 50 times to wipe it up when I got
to the door I was soaking wet her
husband came and a very fine man by the
way he looked at me and I was just so he
has better come in quickly and then he
brought his wife out and she was Stern
and then she saw me and then he became
motherly and I was treated like the boy
that and they got me clean clothes they
made me were their clothes and so forth
and so on and then he said to me get her
to show you the pictures and I didn't
know it in a minute and I said your
husband mentioned something about
pictures oh you mean the pictures I have
of Ava brown and so forth and would you
like those I said I certainly would if
you've read the insane saying my book on
Hitler you'll see a number of the
pictures there that had never been seen
before that she just gave me all these
pictures these marvelous but what I
particularly like i don't i don't know
if i published or not anyway it's a
beautiful picture of Ava she's naked but
doesn't you don't see anything it's a
very artistic picture and she let me
have that and I have a
I had all these pictures and so forth
and I didn't do a thing and I believed
that the somebody's helping me it must
be so many things have happened to me
like you remember I tell about I had to
go to do extra and so I had to make
money so I worked in the North Tower and
rubber company is the boy running around
and I was thinking of my stories and I
fell down an elevator shaft because the
guy forgotten the whole offense and I
remember his boy I was stunned and then
I heard this grinding noise and I looked
up and it's coming down I am notoriously
slow I have notoriously look at my hands
the young man that had coming down when
he's he was shocked he saw me standing
in this one place I could have leaped
into in my ordinary days I couldn't have
climbed into their I don't know how I
got there what if what did it but this
has happened to me I've ever had about
five or six slices with I walked into
Lake Okoboji when I was two years old
went over my head and my uncle had to
jump down from his room and pulled me
out I was always climbing out on ruse
when I was a baby I was and once I when
I was a year old i was in my my my
diaper and I I had got my father's hat
which came over my nose and I was
walking up the rail the trolley tracks
and my mother said that this trolley
almost ran me down the conductor came
out and went up to his mrs. Toland does
this belong to you well somebody was
always saving me what what are you going
to do now that you've decided not to
write anymore I want to help my children
naturally I just have ever been to block
island it's a wonderful place because
the
their automobiles come in last verse huh
where is it block island is off
Providence yeah it takes about 90 minute
to go buy a ferry boat over there and
it's not a big place but I tell you it's
a wonderful place that while I was over
there I met about six people I've known
for years just out of the blue meeting
these people but i like it because
everybody is polite and like in cars if
the other they have one policeman i
think in the whole place or something
like that and he drives slowly but the
first people think of are the
pedestrians and then the bicyclist and
so forth and then cars come in last and
I've noticed with cars when you come up
to a faraway place to be about força
every car is waiting for the next one
politely you've never seen and this
there's no signs they have stop signs
and that's about or what no traffic
lights or anything nobody nobody was
hurt and so forth and I just like the
whole idea of people thinking of other
people and that's why I think and then
now they feel Oh John you know them a
lot of millionaires are making I don't
care who's doing it whatever it is it's
a i recommended highlight for people
that want to spend a quiet holiday how
well do you think this will sell and how
many books did they print first printing
I have no idea I'm getting a lot of
letters some people that so many people
write me about it and I hope it sells
well our guest has been John Tolin and
the book is called captured by history
thank you very much for joining us John
Tolin won the 1971 pulitzer prize for
nonfiction for the rising sun he died
january fourth in Danbury Connecticut at
the age of 91
[Music]